لمحة نادرة داخل قطار بوتين السري
مع وثائق مسربة عُرضت على رئيس شبكة سي إن إن
تكشف كيف يسافر زعيم الكرملين
وسط إجراءات أمنية مشددة
ورفاهية متزايدة، فأنت محاط بالأعداء
ويريد نفسيًا أن يشعر
بالحماية
من خارج القطار رقم واحد كما
يطلق عليه في روسيا  يبدو الأمر عاديًا، فهي
عربات مدرعة ثقيلة
مقنعة عمدًا بطلاء السكك الحديدية الروسية العادية
والأوساخ،
وقد سُمح لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية ذات مرة بالدخول إلى
تسجيل لقاء الرئيس بوتين
بمسؤولي النقل في
قاعة اجتماعات فخمة، وظلت عربات القطار الأخرى البالغ عددها 20 عربة أو نحو ذلك، والتي تم
تحديث بعضها مؤخرًا في
العام الماضي، تحت
حراسة مشددة.  خدمة الشكر السرية حتى الآن
هي شركة روسية تصنع
ما تسميه سيارات النخبة
لعملائها المتخصصين في التصميمات الفاخرة
للشركات الخاصة والحكومية بالطبع من
بين مجموعة كبيرة من الوثائق بما في ذلك
المخططات والرسائل والصور التي حصل عليها
حصريًا
مركز ملفات التحقيق الروسي و  تمت مشاركتها مع CNN، وهي
واحدة من خدمة Zircon مؤرخة في أغسطس
2018،
تخطر الكرملين بإجراء اختبار
لما تسميه العربة الصحية الرياضية
التي تم طلبها،
وتظهر الصور المصاحبة ما
يقول مركز الملف إنها
صالة الألعاب الرياضية الخاصة لبوتين على متن القطار
في العام الماضي.  وكان الكرملين
يتطلع إلى تحديث صالة الألعاب الرياضية
بمعدات أمريكية لتحل محل
الآلات الإيطالية التي قام بتركيبها في الأصل
عضو سابق في
خدمة الحماية الشخصية لبوتين، والذي قال إنه قام بتركيب
معدات الاتصالات الآمنة في القطار قبل الانشقاق من روسيا،
أخبر مركز الملفات أن
زعيم الكرملين بدأ السفر بالقطار.  بشكل أكثر
انتظامًا في الفترة التي سبقت
غزو أوكرانيا العام الماضي
هو
[موسيقى]
ولكن تقدير الرئيس الروسي
لا يعني الانزعاج، كما تظهر خطط مسربة
للقطار أيضًا منتجعًا صحيًا فاخرًا على
متنه بما في ذلك حمام بخار تركي
وفقًا لملف المركز
جناح تجميل مجهز بالكامل مع
طاولة للتدليك ومعدات تجميل متطورة،
يشكك الكرملين الآن في
النتائج التي توصل إليها مركز الملف، حيث أخبر شبكة CNN أن
الرئيس بوتين لا يمتلك ولا يستخدم
عربة سكة حديد مثل تلك الموصوفة ولكن
في أعقاب التمرد المسلح الأخير
هنا في  روسيا التي
تعرضت فيها سلطة بوتين للتهديد، أصبح
التركيز على وجوده المنعزل
أعلى من أي وقت مضى،
وتؤكد فكرة تدليل بوتين أثناء سفره متخفيًا بواسطة قطار مصفح كيف
أصبح زعيم الكرملين المنعزل بشكل غريب مصابًا بجنون العظمة
ومحاصرًا وفقًا لكاتب خطاباته السابق.
هل تعتقد أن فلاديمير
بوتين والكرملين قد أنفقا مثل هذه
المبالغ الكبيرة من المال في التخطيط
وبناء مبنى التدريب الرئاسي المدرع هذا،
حيث يحظى بشعبية متزايدة، فهو
يحصل على المزيد والمزيد من الأعداء الذين يرتكبون
المزيد والمزيد من
الأعداد الأولية، ولا يمكنك بناء منشأة الجدران السياسية التي
تريد بناءها بها
الجدران الخرسانية والدروع،
الدفاع الجسدي،
هناك علامات على أن هذه الصورة
يعرف الكرملين أنه يجب أن يشكلها في
الأسابيع الأخيرة، وقد شهدت بوتين أكثر
انخراطًا علنًا مما كان عليه منذ سنوات،
ولكن في عالمه العدائي بشكل متزايد،
فإن الأمن والرفاهية في القطار رقم
واحد
ربما ملاذ
ماثيو فرصة سي إن إن موسكو